good morning everyone thank you for
being here on such a lovely Sunday
morning in Berlin today I will talk to
you about privacy preserving data
sharing in general and yeah so the whole
morning the whole tract was about data
privacy and ethics of data science and
this is exactly in in this team a little
background about myself I'm leading the
data science efforts at status and
mainly working and exactly this of
privacy preserving data sharing and I
want to share with you some of the
learnings that we had dealing with with
with this topic and what we see that is
done today in the privacy preserving
preservation field the talk will be
introductory so if you're not familiar
with data privacy mechanisms hopefully
you would get pointers to to go and
explore for further four things how not
to do things and how maybe to do things
so I'll start by introducing the privacy
notion why is it important and and then
the more into the mechanisms that have
been used on or still in use in in order
to share data sets and some of them are
kind of not go to things anymore and so
I'm I'm going to show why not to use
them while others are kind of more
trendy these days and constitute the
state of the art so what is privacy
according to the English dictionary
privacy is a state in which one is not
observed or disturbed by other people
some considered fundamental right and
this for several reasons and one most
important reason I'll say is that a lack
of privacy
induces behavioral changes in
individuals and as a consequence change
in how the society works in general so
to the right I'm showing a picture of
this design and the Pentagon is
panopticon so this is a prison design
and basically the cells are disposed in
a circular fashion with a watch our
single watch show in the middle and the
idea is that if the prisoners think they
may be observed in any single point in
time
even when they are not observed they
actually behave as if they were observed
and this is actually changing their
behaviors and and because of this type
of reasons we have some mechanisms in
our free societies that guarantee the
freedom of choice in the actions which
is to make and for instance anonymous
voting is basically guaranteeing that
each and every one vote for for for the
person or idea that he thinks right and
not fall because of feeling of some
consequences so today when we talk about
privacy mainly in the digital era we
realize that most of our actions when we
use digital communications are logged
are tracked or used in a variety of ways
so websites that we browse that the
clicks in the locations so the places we
go to some shopping DC's if we use a
credit card everything is is used either
by some private companies or I would say
maybe worst case mmm some national
agencies and this had especially
recently then there was these room
Snowden revelations for instance that
showed the scale of this happening but
okay and we see that it's everything is
being tracked but at the same time
can can we do is it necessary that we
just withhold all all the data and this
is not necessarily true
so privacy is not necessarily complete
non-disclosure and an example of this is
that when you go to your text come look
accountant or to your doctor you're
actually sharing some very sensitive
data and you don't feel as if there's a
lack of privacy by doing so because
there's some kind of implicit or
sometimes even explicit trust contract
between you and your doctor that allows
you to feel safe by sharing this
information and at the same time you
realize that if you want the service
well it's actually necessary to share
this information otherwise you don't get
anything so this is true at the
individual level but this is also true
at more collective level so the society
in general would benefit from
individuals sharing their individual
data points medical advances and
research has been built on patients kind
of willing to to share their cases
service for sociological research has
built also on this willingness to to
share your sensitive information to to
gain insights from it and some examples
and quickly even when the information
being tracked is digital is for instance
search engine queries that could
identify outbursts of diseases almost in
real-time so this is some benefit that
any society could want by their
individuals sharing their data the thing
is it's quite challenging at and it
sometimes causes massive harm as we've
seen in some cases where companies have
shared their data but it went incredibly
around and I'm going a little bit more
in the details of some of these gay
is when I go into the privacy preserving
mechanisms of the people throughout the
last decades have tried so this is an
illustration data set that I will use as
a as a base for the explanation there
there are several attributes usually in
this kind of data set some are directly
identifying such as the name the phone
others well maybe not so much because
many people share some attributes the
birth year than the sex the zipcode and
then there's usually some sensitive
information from here and medical
condition and then sometimes you may
have some other type of information that
could look cryptic so for instance here
it's just a time series of whether a
person had a headache a certain day or
not so just one if year zero otherwise
and let's start with the first one so
this is what usually is called
personally identifying information so
this is information that could almost
directly identify any given person and
if a data set is shared with this
information in it well basically you
have no doubt that it will cause kind of
harm directly to the people in it
because it's obvious and this is exactly
what happened in the cam bridge analogy
care with Facebook data leaked the
information that what got in the first
place was voluntary voluntary if we will
bomb by the Facebook users was I think
thirty thousand people who gave their
personality traits and at the same time
kind of access to their personal data
and the personal data of their friends
so this data had the names and a lot of
other detailed personal information that
that this company used later on to build
personality profile and then cross with
both religion register in
to craft highly targeted ads to show
again to a large number of people and
supposedly influence in the American
elections so what is the solution is it
just to remove all personally
identifying information and actually
this is widely used today in the
industry many companies still just use
this metal to just remove the names and
then and and then release the data set
some college students ations I'm called
sanitization the identification some
even call it anonymization and if we
remove this we are we are we remove the
first column then we have the the others
and the second type of attributes I
would like to focus on is is this
attribute that that are not unique to
you taken one at a time but if you
combine them as I said in his previous
talk if you combine them that you get
actually quite unique information about
people so the researcher Latanya Sweeney
showed that 87% of Americans are
uniquely identified by a combination of
birthdate sex and zip code so basically
this as if you are releasing the names
so if this again that doesn't work
either because if you do this you can
still identify as I said the people
based on these attributes and this is
exactly what
Latanya Sweeney explore exploited in the
Massachusetts group insurance Commission
where medical data about state employees
had been released so it was a hire very
detailed
it had this zip birthdate and sex and
then it had all the medical history of
individuals the visit dates the
medication the procedure that diagnosis
this was highly sensitive and they
released it they just removed the name
and released the beta cell so what this
researcher did she she purchased voter
registers and there is publicly
available you can just pay twenty
dollars and get the whole file and she
managed to join this voter list list
that had the name and address with with
this medical data set and from this she
managed to build the medical file of the
Massachusetts governor at the time and
then she sent him to the whole pile
another another type of information that
a little bit less obvious is this kind
of thing so you have something for
instance product visits or some some
time series about something happening or
or not or movie preferences and you
could say that this is not really
personal data because many people do the
same thing and I like to think about
these kind of attributes as finger light
in a fingerprint like information so
when you look at two fingerprints from
from from a distance well they kind of
look very similar to somebody who's not
used to them but if you check the
details you realize that every
fingerprint is unique and this is the
same for for this kind of information
most of the time the more dimensions you
have the more uniqueness is in the data
and then they and the more you need to
consider them as highly sensitive as
well or at least identifying
and as an illustration to this kind of
attributes and there's the movie
preferences and this was very famous
attack on the Netflix price data set so
Netflix wanted to get a new more
performant recommender system so they
just released pseudonymous data for
their users movie preferences and asked
researches to apply different algorithm
on them and try the best and magic of
Vitaly and Narayanan took the data set
but they didn't build the recommender
engine instead they they went to IMDB
and as well took it the movie
preferences from IMDB and what they
found is that you can join you uniquely
identify people in enlarged proportions
just based on four to five movies
especially if the movies are not very
popular so here they showed but with
four or five movies you could identify
more than 80% of the people even though
the data in the first place was just a
number from one to five in different
days for with a certain set of movies
another example of another fail is the
Strawberry interact this is more recent
this was early this year Strava has is a
running and sport tracking app they
released a service called the heat map
and basically what it shows is where the
people run or where the people cycle and
they have 30 million Reynolds worldwide
so there's just released these heat maps
and all over the world and as you can
see here well 30 million runners maybe
but not set that much in in this area it
looks quite quite dark and when you look
at in the details
again you can identify some points that
were light in the middle of the desert
and another researcher managed to
identify some military bases and some of
them were actually secret and ok this is
a case of aggregates but with Strava
you could also identify single single
individuals in France it was possible to
identify a secret agent because he was
jugging from the his job at midday and
and and then you could cross this with
with public races times and and because
he was tracking the same thing both in
strata and and and it was also publicly
tracked well you could just join because
it was on straightforward many more of
course and the common issue between all
these approaches is that the attack
could just it's quite simple you just
need an oxidant dataset and then you can
link your your your main data set with
another publicly available data set or
some data set that you you you find
somewhere either legally or illegally I
mean your if you're an attacker you
probably don't care that much and this
auxiliary data set itself may contain
personally identifiable information
which means that you managed to identify
single records so what's the take away
and take away here is just that
pseudonym ization is not enough and we
realized that many people are still
thinking about pseudonym ization when
they talk about analyzation whenever you
hear a sentence such as we do not share
data in any personally identifiable way
most of the time people are talking
about pseudonym ization and yeah as I
just showed it's it doesn't work so as a
solution and the insanely researcher
that exposed the Massachusetts governor
medical file came up with K and anime
with the main goal of avoiding these
unique joints that let constitute the
privacy bridge so she focuses on them
quasi identifiers these are these
attributes that are not necessarily
unique to you but they are when you take
them in combinations and then she makes
sure that each combination appears at
least K times so that when you join it
with another data set you have K rows
and by doing so then you're not singling
out any single record and the main
techniques are generalization so you
generalize the values you don't keep the
highest level of granularity and you can
suppress the outliers for instance and
here I'm looking at an example so the
same data set and we will go from this
one here to the left as an original data
set to the one to the right as a three
animals data set so the three anonymous
means that every combination has three
records mmm
so for instance we remove the last three
digits of a zip code and then we we just
suppress the whole sex column so we
don't care about it because otherwise we
cannot okay anonymize these three last
records okay so how it works we see that
if we have this person here and we want
to check it out or identify it in this
data set well if we check these
combinations then it can be any of these
three and and these three well they have
different medical conditions so we we
don't infer them the sensitive
information about this person so it
seems like knme tea worked in this case
except that it works in in in in some
case but in many others it has some
shortcomings and and here I'm showing
two cases where it doesn't work there
are others but these ones are under the
most straightforward so if I have
black born in 65 and female then it can
be either of these three except that
when you check the medical condition
well they are the same so you still know
that this person has a heart disease
even though there were three people
because all of them had the heart
disease another one is called the
background knowledge attack is for
instance this second case when you have
three people and and when you look at
the medical condition the sensitive
information if you have some background
knowledge about this medical condition
well you realize that this person here
male could only have one of them and
basically you're identifying the person
so in these cases it doesn't really work
so there are other variants that try to
solve the problem but they suffer from
the main issue which is that the this
guarantee is mainly syntactic so it
doesn't have any knowledge of the
sensitive information it's trying to
protect and or the the background
knowledge of the attacker also if you
have many dimensions in your course he
identifies it's actually even hard to
achieve this Kay anonymity on its own so
without talking about the background
knowledge because the more dimensions
that you have the harder it becomes to
define some closeness between between
the records so the takeaway from from
this one is mainly to just assume the
worst especially or attack scenarios the
attacker is not limited he can have or
she can have many information about the
data she's dealing with auxilary data
sets everything computational power so
any methods trying to preserve privacy
need to take this into account so
now I will try to think more about what
can we expect when we try to to
guarantee some kind of privacy
especially there as we seen syntactic
guarantees don't seem to work and one
one of the promises is to say okay I'm
giving you my data but I don't want it
to have any effect on any analysis at
all it's as if I'm not giving you my
data in the first place is like you're
opting out of the of the study but the
thing is if nobody's data has any effect
on any analysis well there will be no
utility at all when you're trying to
analyze the data the second one is is
more general so I say I have a secret
and I'm giving you my data but I want
that the probability of you knowing my
secret
after analyzing the data is the same as
the probability of you know in my secret
before analyzing the data so basically
I'm telling you I don't want you to
learn anything more about my secret by
analyzing the data the problem is that
this promise is also impossible to
achieve because if the secret does not
concern only me it's not specific to me
then it can generally be learned from
other people so even if your data is not
in the data set in the first place you
can still learn things about your secret
not because your data was in the data
set but because other people had the
same secret is you so it's also
impossible to guarantee this and one
trade off promise is one that states
that with or without my data I wanted
any outcome of any analysis but on a
data set would be almost equally likely
so what I'm saying here is that I wanted
the impact of me sharing my in
Meishan will be limited to just the
general earnings from the data not the
specifics of my information and this is
exactly the the the promise that a
formal definition of privacy has
formalized it's called the differential
privacy
it was ya then 10 12 years ago mmm so
yeah not really very recent but then
still has limited adoption and what it
states is that you have possible world
including your data and another possible
world excluding your data and then you
carry some analysis on it and getting a
result what it says is that the
probabilities of this result in in both
cases would be sensibly the same and if
you write it in a nice formula it just
says that the ratio of probabilities is
bounded by by a small number and so it's
it's not an algorithm it's a definition
and in order to satisfy the definition
you can use different mechanisms that
I'm here just given the intuition I'm
not going really into the details either
of differential privacy or different
mechanisms we'll just given the
intuition so one such mechanism that
satisfies it is called the Laplace
mechanism and the idea is to add to add
a noise that follows also hit this is a
random variable that follows laplacian
distribution and here on the X we have
the possible outputs those possible
outcomes and on the Y's the
probabilities and what it shows that if
you add the laplacian noise to to result
of an analysis of a query when it's
numerical then the this ratio is bounded
by my by a small number thus satisfying
the differential privacy
formula so the advantages is it has a
nice theoretical definition no
assumptions about the attack scenario
it's it's really in the process so by
design and not at the output and it also
has a composition theorem so you could
actually compose different algorithms
that satisfy this property and still be
able to reason about the guarantees and
and the utility behind it it has many
drawbacks as well another one is also
the fact of having multiple queries
could lead to some situations where if
you ask many queries at the same time
you could at some point to remove the
noise and infer the true answer usually
it's not that easy to find
differentially private mechanism in
complex cases if you don't have
numerical data set or if they have high
sensitivity and one main drawback is the
adoption that's still quite limited so a
lot of research is still going on in
this and you should be prepared to to to
kind of stay on top it's used in data
release mostly for aggregates so the US
Census Bureau uses it for releasing
histograms and contingency tables and it
works quite well the challenge is to
maintain can consistency between
different sets of ways so that they
complement each other and and you find
you don't have any consistency when you
check the results and if we want to have
really truly the data at the same
granularity then it's a bit more tricky
and fourth mechanism I would like to
talk about is data synthesis ation and
one illustration of data synthesis in or
in the intuition behind this design
situation is
trying to learn the distribution of your
dataset here I'm looking at
anthropometric data of the u.s. army so
you have touch height and the weight and
I'm checking the Joint Distribution so
this is the original data and if you
want to synthesize it you have to learn
the underlying distribution and then you
can sample a new element from it so this
is just the idea the thing is if you
just do it this way you still are not
going gene privacy because if you know
exactly the mean or exactly some
properties you can still infer
information about individuals if they
have a very large contribution to this
result so one possible way to deal with
this is to combine the ether synthesis
ation with differential privacy by
learning the distribution in a
differentially private way and and then
you can synthesize from it yeah so
applications of data synthesis ation
usually because they you keep the same
granularity then you can use it as if it
was the original data so you can use it
if you are in software development
process you could use it in development
phases you could use it to limit access
to real data if if you have sensitive
information and replace it with
synthetic data when possible you could
also share it for exploration purposes
if you for instance in the Netflix case
if you want other researchers to work on
your data develop models and then maybe
you want to apply it on the real data
afterwards and then some final notes I
think the most important is that sudonym
ization is not really an animation so
just do not use it I remember 8 years
ago I was working on a project and we
actually did this thinking that it was
enough to anonymize the data it's it
it's wrong hopefully today the legal
constraints and and in Journal also the
scandals around data privacy would be a
trigger for organizations to consider
this question more seriously and to look
for better privacy preserving mechanisms
yeah and other things you conclude is
that privacy preserve and data release
is still an open question for for many
cases it works for for many cases but
for others it's still ongoing topic so
if your researcher are interested in the
question is there are so many things to
do thank you thank you very much so the
topic of anonymizing data or all the
nice notions you you displayed any
questions from the audience we film
more of a request for to expand on a
theme than a question so I'm guessing
lots of people here are training
particular types of algorithms on
datasets I've seen a couple of attempts
to anonymize data set
considering the utility right so yeah
given that I am going to use this to
train this type of model I can
synthesize around the original data
points in this particular way and then
delete the originals but that's
relatively tied to the utility there's
something that you've been exploring at
all kind of when when it will probably
be useless for anything else but for
this particular purpose this data set
will actually do well so sir what was
the last part so the question is if
you've been exploring also these
questions where the data set that gets
released maybe to the research team is
tied to the utility which they need it
for and would not actually be useful for
anything else because it's been
anonymized yeah that utility it's a it's
a it's a very good question and there
are different approaches and so the
first one is if you really know the
algorithm sometimes there are private
implementations of the specific
algorithm so if if you know that you
want to have this task and you know that
you want to use this particular
algorithm then you you can have this
private implementation there are many
algorithms and then run them for us for
instance or many algorithms that have
private implementations that you could
use this is the first point the single
point if you know the exact question
you're looking for then you can do the
synthesis ation with this in mind but
but then you would be focusing on some
question but losing the general
generality of your of your data set and
the third case which is I would say the
holy grail of sensitization is to have a
completely generic process that
preserves all the all the properties so
that's what we are trying to do and it's
also an open question so many people are
trying to do the same the thing is that
it's still difficult to have all other
than the statistical property that the
questions if you can not for instance
and preserve outliers if you're actually
looking for privacy preserve anything
because an outlier is the most sensitive
probably or the first one to get lost of
these kind of considerations or aren't
you keep in mind but it is possible in
some cases okay we have one Jin let's
first thanks for the talk
in case of Kay anonymity do you think
that if your dataset is is without those
edge cases you solved with the
background example if it's not like for
you so it's the main issue with Kay
anonymity is that it has the first
statement is there are quasi identifiers
so there are some attributes that we
care about the thing is this statement
is false because all the attributes are
actually identifying and if you're
trying to do to preserve it at a whole
at the whole level of all the attributes
I would say it depends it's not really
yeah
I had more of a technical question about
one of your fruit slides with the
headache patterns you know you said that
you know don't hire dimensionality the
more identifiable they are yes I agree
put exactly this is also the signal that
you're after right sorry so this is
exactly the signal in the data that
you're after
yes so what's your advice in this case I
mean should you try to also minimize
this or I mean it in itself it's useless
without any additional data set which
has exactly this identifiers and some
other personal data so I mean in this
particular case what would you do
so the question is if you have many
dimensions and other sensitive
information right we are like in the
headache data like in the headache
dataset sorry I really like like
headache patterns oh yeah okay cool so
the the one that that I'm using
personally for for this kind of
information is to try and learn the
underlying distribution hopefully in a
privacy-preserving way so you try to
this headache data so you have different
symptoms for instance over several days
and you try to learn how how they occur
and and and from there so you're not
generalizing or you're not adding noise
to specific entries but maturer trying
to produce new ones that kind of
reproduce the same statistical
properties of these of these ones so the
the main point is that you don't release
exactly the same because if you release
exactly the same than you're breaching
the privacy of the first person in in
the first place but if you manage to
learn the statistical properties that
led to these values occurring then you
can still learn from it
from the new date is it thank you okay
if there are any maybe we have time for
one more question here and yeah I'll
eventually become hated by the audience
my question is about one thing which was
not mentioned and I don't know it's
probably quite a naive question but how
far or how viable and conceptually is it
that datasets can actually be hashed and
still remain useful for for machine
learning in general so this is another
whole new other topic I'm not very
familiar with the question but yeah I'm
so I wouldn't try and answer on this but
there are things going in that direction
homomorphic encryption is one such
direction where you could hash the data
encrypted and then still be able to run
computations on top of the encrypted and
data set you are most of the time
limited to what kind of computations you
can still do and to the speed of
computations but it's a direction that's
definitely worth exploring thank you
Thanks ok thank you very much Omar again
[Applause]